[Música]
centro de confinamiento del terrorismo
es el nombre de la nueva cárcel del
Salvador construida para contener a los
pandilleros de las maras del país a los
que el presidente nayib bukele les ha
declarado la guerra durante diez meses
de régimen de excepción esto en medio de
denuncias de detenciones arbitrarias a
civiles y violaciones de Derechos
Humanos se cuentan en 175 muertos
durante las redadas de los últimos seis
meses el centro de confinamiento ya es
famoso porque se levantó en apenas siete
meses y adentro vivirán hasta 40.000
delincuentes son estas instalaciones un
paso en la dirección correcta vamos al
análisis y conversamos con Tiziano breda
él es investigador o para el Instituto
afari internacional Muchísimas gracias a
usted por estar con nosotros y comienzo
preguntándole por esta mega cárcel que
es calificada por el gobierno como uno
de los mayores logros de bukele Usted
qué opina
Buenos días Ángela Muchas gracias por la
invitación
Efectivamente es sorpresivo la manera en
que se ha venido construyendo una cárcel
cuyo proyecto fue lanzado apenas unas
semanas después de régimen excepción
pero cuya preparación posiblemente haya
ido pues haya sido anterior no y de
todas formas marcó un cambio enorme en
la política de gobierno frente a las
pandillas porque recordemos que antes de
marzo del 2022
sí había cada vez más evidencia de que
el gobierno de hecho entretenía
conversaciones con las principales
pandillas del país para mantener los
niveles de violencia muy bajos eh frente
a la ruptura de estas conversaciones
negociaciones llaman es como como quiera
el gobierno pues ha dado Este paso de de
campaña de restos masivos que ha
producido decenas de miles de
detenciones de seguramente miembros de
pandillas también miles de detenciones
arbitrarias y que básicamente intenta
enjaular no el problema de las pandillas
al intentar detener cualquier persona
que haya tenido que haya haya tenido o
pueda tener una vinculación con las
pandillas por un tiempo limitado de
tiempo esto puede ser efectivo lo
estamos viendo en los resultados la el
problema es Cuántos cuántos sostenible
es esto en el tiempo y cuáles van a ser
las consecuencias
de reacomodo de estas organizaciones y
de la inseguridad en general frente a
este cambio en las comunidades incluso
con una menor presencia de las pandillas
y también para finalizar un poco cómo
está relacionado este esta campaña con
el proyecto político de bukele porque ha
sido posible solamente gracias al hecho
de que El Ejecutivo tiene una presencia
enorme en las diferentes instituciones y
ramas del estado y eso ha hecho posible
esta esta depresión pues hablemos de
esas consecuencias Y de esa
sostenibilidad desde esta política de
encarcelamiento a largo plazo porque se
estrena esta cárcel con la que bukele
promete varias cosas entre ellas que es
imposible escapar que es imposible que
se organicen en las cárceles y que
puedan seguir delinquiendo tras las
rejas pero pues Habría que ver qué tan
factible Es que esto sucede y que
realmente haya una erradicación de la
violencia de pandillas en El Salvador
pues seguramente ha mejorado mucho la
gestión de las cárceles y esto viene
desde antes del gobierno de bukele
particularmente a raíz a partir de 2016
cuando se introdujeron medidas
excepcionales extraordinarias en las
cárceles que aislaban mucho más a los
líderes pandilleros ahí recluidos que
antes en cambio pues mandaban
básicamente desde las cárceles esto ha
venido a Costa de el respeto de los
Derechos básicos de los detenidos porque
hay que recordar que hay detenidos
líderes pero también pandilleros de
menor Rango que no ven por ejemplo a sus
familiares desde hace unos siete años
básicamente
entonces hay que ver cuál es el balance
que se quiere hacer entre políticas de
seguridad Buscar mejorar la situación de
seguridad del país pero también con
respecto al debido proceso a los
derechos de los de los reos y sobre todo
a la finalidad con las cuales se ponen
detrás del área de las personas es un
simplemente para intentar erradicarlas
del territorio o es para reformar los
que se puedan reformar y buscar una
reinserción en algún momento en la
sociedad Parece que la primera el primer
método o el primer objetivo es el que se
está persiguiendo y claramente esto
puede en cambio generar o alimentar
hostilidades en las comunidades en
prácticamente en las familias no de los
familiares de los de los pandilleros
que se encuentran en una situación
claramente eh muy complicada y es donde
en un país donde hay disponibilidad de
armas una cultura de la violencia bien
arraigada eh una marginación de los
territorios pocas oportunidades
económicas y mucha pobreza bueno Esto
puede mutar no el fenómeno de la
inseguridad tal vez no sean las
pandillas y las que tengan el monopolio
sobre la criminalidad o las economías
ilícitas sino que también puede
fragmentar
digamos esta inseguridad con la con el
nacimiento de varios grupos o incluso de
criminales comunes que de todas formas
sigan delinquiendo en el país crean
alimentando una situación tal vez menos
violenta Pero eso no significa que sea
menos insegura Habría que ver la
política pública que tendría que
implementar bukele después ahora él dice
que ha capturado más de 60.000
pandilleros watch ustedes ya lo estaba
diciendo por encima denuncia
hacinamiento extremo o procesos
judiciales irregulares muertes bajo
custodia además hay cientos de menores
que están incluidos en estos arrestos
entonces Más allá de que estén bajando
las cifras Pues cuál es el precio en
derechos humanos que está pagando el
Salvador
precisamente eso a lo que hace
referencia de repente han sido muy
exitosos porque tenían una base de datos
muy amplia sobre ya pandilleros que
habían ingresado en algún momento al
sistema judicial
etcétera y entonces eso ha permitido que
las autoridades pues detuvieran
efectivamente decenas de miles de
personas vinculadas a estos grupos
Aunque posiblemente ya habían pagado por
los crímenes que que habían cometido hay
mucha gente que nos constan me consta
que que había dejado había intentado
dejar la vida de pandilla a través sobre
todo las conversiones religiosa y de
todas formas ha sido
digamos
agarrada en medio de este de estas
masivas Entonces
ese es el problema o sea eso es posible
solamente cuando El Ejecutivo controla o
tiene una influencia muy fuerte sobre el
lo judicial sobre las fuerzas de
seguridad sobre el legislativo que ha
venido extendiendo este estado de
excepción que ya no es de excepción sino
que es permanente
y por lo tanto los resultados de
seguridad pues van visto también en
óptica de
retrocesos democráticos y así queremos
llamarlos y y por lo tanto Pues habría
que buscar un balance no entre entre
estos dos para que una política sea más
sostenible en el tiempo y no la
seguridad no venga a Costa de las
libertades individuales porque hoy son
los pandilleros o la gente que podría
estar involucrada con las pandillas pero
mañana podrían ser simplemente pues
activistas o otras franjas de la
sociedad
y
viendo sus derechos restringidos pues
puedan pagar el precio de estas de estas
medidas bien nos queda menos de un
minuto y ya para mi última pregunta
buque le asegura además que El Salvador
pasó de ser el país más peligroso del
mundo al país más seguro del continente
americano ustedes está de acuerdo con
esto que dice bukele y pues bueno Cómo
se puede en el final medir a largo plazo
los resultados de estas capturas que se
están dando hoy
Pues es indudable que las cifras de
homicidios habían habían bajado de
manera considerable
hay que poner algunos puntos
interrogativos sobre el hecho de que
estas cifras mismas hayan sido muy
difíciles de corroborar porque el
gobierno a básicamente secretado
las los índices de homicidios donde
ocurren sean también dividido lo que son
muertes en enfrentamientos supuestos
enfrentamientos entre pandilleros y
fuerza de seguridad donde caigan
pandilleros en estos enfrentamientos
bueno no se cuentan como homicidios Y
antes se hacía Entonces es un poco
altera la posibilidad de de comparar
cifras con los años anteriores dicho eso
Seguramente
se han desbaratado las estructuras
pandillerías en los últimos meses que
están manteniendo perfiles más bajos
muchos han huido muchos han sido
detenidos Entonces ha bajado la
intensidad de la de la violencia
perpetrada por esos grupos pero como
decíamos antes Pues habrá que ver si
esto en el tiempo es sostenible o si las
pandillas buscarán la forma u otros
grupos buscarán la forma de llenar este
vacío de reagruparse y de perpetrar otra
vez actos de violencia que puedan
alterar estas